I'm the lucky one come to Scandinavia
[Applause]
back in 1998 you you were a part of a
neo-nazi group and you were arrested for
hate crimes yes and and imprisoned three
years yes
and prison would change everything for
you how did that happen well I walked
into prison at the age of 23 thinking
that I was gonna spend whatever time
there with my back against the wall you
know people were gonna attack me because
of who I was and what actually happened
there was the furthest thing from what I
thought was going to happen I in a
nutshell can tell you sitting there one
day
in a wreck you know area where women are
playing games there was this woman of
color that kept looking at me and she
was giving me this eye and I was
thinking she's gonna jump me she's gonna
fight me she knows who I am and she just
looked at me and said hey you know how
to play cribbage and I said what the
[__] is cribbage cribbage is a game with
a board with pegs and numbers and you
use it with cards and that was you know
my attitude was to be tough and she
picked up this game and came over and
sat next to me and taught me how to play
this game so from you know very early on
all my preconceived notions not only of
my time there but of other people blown
right out of the water
and did people know who you were well it
was that absolutely I was involved in a
hate crime case that was highly
publicized all over the news and the
newspapers so plus I had racist tattoos
all over my body that I couldn't cover
all of them so everyone knew who I was
and why I was there and she still chose
to treat me with kindness and for some
reason this group of Jamaican women you
know we just kind of
took that woman was Jamaican and they
you know over three years time taught me
so much about what it meant to be a
human being and as they treated me as a
human being I learned to view myself the
very same way again and you even fell in
love I did I fell in love how it must
have been surprising even for you
it was definitely a shocker and being I
know this is gonna sound crazy but being
in that prison was the freest I had ever
felt in my entire life up until that
point I could be me I didn't have to be
angry I didn't have to be aggressive I
didn't you know if feel like I had to
change or be something for other people
and it yeah it was a shocker but it was
a life changer you you said you are
tattooed would not see symbols do you
still have any I've gotten almost all of
them covered I do still have a few that
are in odd places for instance I have
something tattooed on the inside of my
bottom lip that I probably will never
get covered up because it's you know no
one can really see it unless I show them
or the dentist I have to give him the
disclaimer every time I go like please
don't judge me for what you see there
Kenya shows sure what when you when you
had that to to who were you then let's
let's go back I mean this was an angry
person yeah I was a very angry confused
young woman that didn't know her place
in the world that didn't know who she
was
that didn't know she deserved to be
loved
that didn't know that she was a human
being that deserved to be treated like a
human being what kind of family you
mentioned it was a racist family mm-hmm
tell me about about it what was the
culture like the values my parents were
strict you know they demanded good
grades very you know high grades from my
siblings and I we had a lot of organized
religion shoved at us they were kind of
hypocritical they drank they smoked they
partied but also at the same time from
as early as I could remember I learned
racial slurs stereotypes homophobic
slurs and very much got the feeling that
number one I was better than some
because of the color of my skin and
number two that I had to fear people who
were different in any way did did being
I mean going to school did that did that
help you or did it make the anger worse
school cultivated a lot of the anger I
was bullied quite a bit I have struggled
with my weight my entire life from you
know very early in childhood I would
gain weight and lose it and gain weight
and lose it and you know for some reason
as human beings we sometimes like to see
our fellow human beings humiliated and
you know I was picked on for wearing
glasses for being overweight for not
fitting in for having braces for you
know not dressing the way my peers did
so being in school and dealing with all
of that plus the confusion about my
sexuality this anger just started to
build and build and build and so I would
you answered them or did you I mean how
did you respond to the bullying in the
very beginning I was very meek and timid
and afraid so I would do anything I
could to extricate myself from any
situation where I would be made fun of
or picked on
for most of it it was verbal I was spit
at once and then when I was about 12 was
the first time I was physically bullied
and it was horrific even today I can
feel myself getting red just talking
about it I was in the seventh grade and
I was you know overweight I didn't wear
cool clothes I didn't fit in I had you
know my adolescent training bra on and
the school bully picked a fight with me
and ripped my shirt open in front of the
entire class and that was the last time
because I became the bully that day so
then the tables turn yes you you became
a member of this neo-nazi group what
could they offer what was it that was
the attraction there believe it or not
it had nothing to do with the way I was
raised it had nothing to do with the
belief system the ideology nothing it
all had to do with the fact that they
accepted me yeah they accepted my anger
they accepted my aggression I never had
to explain it they allowed me to be part
of their circle without question and
that was the clincher right there
because I just I wanted to be accepted I
wanted to be loved I wanted to feel like
I was a part of something
were you I mean so you stayed there but
but were you also one I mean they say
you were violent
what kind of violent violence are we
talking about I was known for my
violence I would be asked to do certain
things so for instance there's not
nearly as many women involved as men so
if something happened with another woman
I would have maybe the men say so and so
did this can you take care of her for us
and I was always willing to do it I
thought they'll like me more I'll fit in
more they'll accept me more they'll love
me
I got into a lot of fights surprisingly
I got into more altercations with other
white people than people of color
or you know people of other religions
what would you say is your biggest
regret when you when you that's such a
tough question I know that I can't
change the past I know I can't change
the things that I did to hurt other
people I will probably be apologizing
for the rest of my life but I'm ok with
that because I have the opportunity to
do that and so many people don't I think
most of all I regret hating myself so
much and not not having the courage to
be who I was and to be so afraid of the
young woman that I was I regret that
deeply have you experienced forgiveness
I have I have I had a few years ago I
was contacted by a woman on social media
that I had beaten up pretty badly
at the behest of some of the men and
it's probably gonna make me cry she told
me that the night that I beat her up I
beat the hate out of her and that she
forgave me that very night and that that
is what brought her out of that life was
because she realized that's that's not
what she wanted her life to be and I've
seen that when I allow myself to be
vulnerable and I take full
responsibility you know for everything I
did because I am responsible it doesn't
matter you know that I was raised a
certain way or I had you know bad things
happen to me that really opens doors to
connection you know with fellow human
beings so I have been forgiven and it's
it's not it's not anything that I could
ever ask for
it's a gift given freely today you you
help people in your former situation
defectors yes what do you say to them
are you in with them doesn't help I
liken it to the days when I was a
rebellious teenager and I wanted to do
the opposite of everything I was told I
shouldn't do and I tried to meet people
at their level and remembered that I was
that person at one point so for me I
have to start without judging them which
is very difficult but I also know that
an academic research is showing this
people don't just wake up one day and
decide they hate everyone there are
underlying issues there there you know
are we call them precursors to becoming
involved in violent extremism and it
could be abuse trauma being bullied you
know having things like that happen so
when I talk to them I don't ask them to
talk right off the bat if they're
uncomfortable if they're aggressive I
say can I can I share some of my
experience with you and that kind of
disarms them a little bit because it's
not an automatic lecture you know it's
not a you shouldn't do this because of
all these reasons and one of the hardest
things I've had to learn to do is to be
vulnerable and when I allow myself to do
that then they can sit there and say
that happened to me and I got so angry
and I wanted to hurt other people and it
just it breaks down walls so first I
listen and try to pick out those you
know when they do start talking try to
pick out those things that I can relate
to and say I understand - I'm Janelle
thank you so much hope you enjoyed the
clip for more interesting conversations
please hit subscribe